Have you ever missed a day? No, I have not missed a day and so
Here's uploading every single day. You've never missed. I didn't one do not believe I have missed a day
So do you think you can make a pretty sweet-looking render in the same amount of time it takes people to make something
Yeah
Guess who's coming over today?
Clothes peoples come into their office today
you guys don't know people is I mean
he's one of the most prolific digital artists of our time why it's because for every
Single day for the last 12 years. He has posted and rendered some of the coolest abstract art and posted it to his Instagram
Well, they just Instagram because he's been posting since before Instagram was a thing. See this is the thing
I'm so young that I wasn't even around when he was posting on these other platforms
DeviantART, maybe but that's when he started posting pictures
She's posted so many pictures that if you were to print out every single picture lay it across the ocean
You can you could walk to Hawaii. It's true
Hey Siri, how many days is 12 and a half years four thousand five hundred and sixty five so four and a half
That's a lot of renders four and a half thousand pictures
This guy has made every single day for twelve and a half non-stop years apparently
He hasn't missed a day and apparently he doesn't have backlogs
Apparently he makes each one the day it's posted one
Last time you guys have done something every day consistently for the last month
The point is today is special because he's going to come to our studio and make one of his cool pictures
Wait, wait, wait, hold on that actually the opposite of special because he's made so many that it doesn't matter
Do I have so many I have so many questions to him like right you what's your asset manager like?
What's your what's your content browser look like in cinema 4d is probably curated like the most perfect library of assets
Yes use in pretty much every photo
He ever makes he's figured out a way to put in the least amount of effort to output the maximum picture maximum quality
input and yeah
He's a min put max. Put tie guy, you know, like he's figured it out
So do you think you can make a pretty sweet-looking render in the same amount of time it takes people to make something
Yeah, I could I could probably make something pretty sweet
Maybe maybe not some people quality, but I could render a sphere in a foggy room in 45 minutes guaranteed guaranteed
What if like we each sat down and just try to do our own?
I think we would all make something really cool in the time we have but I would love to see how much better his is
I just want to see like what is his mentality behind like making something because you know
you only have a certain amount of time because otherwise you would just burn out so you have to do it really quickly and
Efficiently, right? Yeah. Yeah. He actually should be here any minute. I've looked up to him for a while
So it's gonna be an honor to have him in the office in the same amount of time that he's working on his every day
We are going to compete and see if we can make one in the same amount of time what he doesn't know though
Is that I've got a button that that will randomly turn off his computer
Giving us an advantage
I have a button that will actually like open up a gap in the floor and drop the seat into a pit
So if like climb that go
He doesn't know about this at all. We decided to Shanghai Amana honors our boat
Peoples here right now. Why are these guys playing Smash Bros? We got a people
Like YouTube crew in America
Six people that have 400 gone
How much time like how much like captain do you guys like uploading like per week
Roughly we put out 30 minutes of polished content last week and that's about our average. Yeah, so like 2 to 3 videos
Like key on all things trick me just holy trick
So I do have like a hard deadline to this and I usually I don't go like 2 minutes to midnight
but it's like literally I have to like do nothing but focus on this that actually happens quite often where
Have you ever missed a day? No, I have not miss a day and
Uploading every single day. You've never missed I even one do not believe I have missed a day. Oh my god. Yeah. Yeah
yeah, do you ever
Do ever stock up on
That's every single day no, no
No, there's definitely no stocking up
Like it's definitely done that day and posted someplace by midnight and some one place by midnight
So we will each have 45 minutes to create own little work of art if my can do it we can do it
But we're going to only work with a small asset pack, which is a collection of 3d models from our own server
It'll definitely push us to use our creativity
In the most amount of ways since when we got so many objects to work with here
other than that
We're gonna be able to use whatever we want inside the programs here using cinema octane and so on and so forth wait
Any ideas it's a little an idea to be in my brain my ideas let that happen
I put a giant tarp over my computer's art isn't a competition. It's a collaboration work on my screen
These guys and copy my style, but I had an idea many times I
Know I'm just thinking dude. I'm just being I'm a creative person. I just think about stuff all the time. Get out
My strat I'm just gonna take one of those 3d models and a blind abstract material to it juxtapose the nature of
industrialization with I don't manatee
I know Sam that he's gonna take the motherboards model and he's gonna take like the cell phone tower model and you scatter on the
Motherboard and call it a day. Oh, so that's where ideas come from
Done and posted by the time this goes off Yes Mother composer this is it every day
No, sir, stop crying what are you five minutes and then we're posting
Okay, there we go 44 minutes in 30 seconds, oh boy, okay
I made a plane people happen to return I do this Scott you real? I got your real friends in there
They're already from the beat himself
they have
38 minutes left to finish render and post
daily follow it's going
My octane scatter is not working. Well, that worked. Don't that that work?
It's already been a full 5 minutes and it's real quiet up in here hasn't been this quiet in this together
Playing goddamn monkey balls or something
Yeah, super monkey ball
During the super monkey ball matches if I wear a blue color shirt cuz I swear that much
You know how these guys they're always all about art
Okay, that's all they ever want to do is just make art they brought in this
guy, the thing is everyone in the studio looks at me as like just do the sponsorship segments and leave us artists to do our
Job. Well, guess what today? Well today is no different. This video is sponsored by Squarespace
But while I'm doing this segment, I'm gonna beat them at their own game
art
All right in order to become an artist it's real simple
Jake you only have 45 minutes you don't worry. Don't worry color contrast
Canvas, it's pretty much it
Okay, so let's get started now because today's episode is brought to you by Squarespace
The piece that I'm gonna make is gonna be inspired by Squarespace
now first things first guys
Squarespace is beautiful award-winning templates mean that whether you're an artist like me or you're a
Musician or you're an online store you've got access to make one of the best websites people are gonna see with Squarespace
Okay now that I've made the square
I'm just gonna clip the edges and then that it'll look like a ticket
the next thing I need to do is show how Squarespace allows you simultaneous posting from your website to your
social media profiles like Twitter and Facebook
I'm gonna put a gradient background behind my admin one ticket in order to represent that symmetry and that perfect balance
The next thing I need to talk about are the traffic overviews that Squarespace allows you to view
I think the perfect thing to represent that is just the classic
artistic image of the all-seeing eye
the final thing that I really need to add into this piece here is this idea of multiple contributors and
Personalization with Squarespace you see? Here's Jake with his
Personalized website, but it's also pointed to the all-seeing eye because he can allow multiple other people to contribute
That's about it guys. I'm gonna render this out
And if you guys are interested in creating your own awesome
Website go to squarespace.com slash corridor crew and you'll get 10% off your first purchase
Okay, the final render is done. Let's check it out
You know
I I think that the metaphors here are so high concept that it might be a little bit difficult for the guys to understand
Yeah, this is really probably I'll save this one. Maybe I'll show maybe like maybe when he leaves I'll shove it
I've never felt fear like this before
I'm just trying to mark direct this but I got I got the final vibe in my head
I just need to just need to execute. All right, I just read over some simple
Composition and symbology here. Just try to make something kind of cool and makes it go Oh neat, it's cool
You put them together like that and that's gonna be extended my project
Are you feeling it 2/3 of the way done I feel pretty good I got my direction I got my vibe
I just need to add some stuff and dude got a post-it man. Got a pretty pose. You see how everybody else is different
Feeling mildly confident
Consuming me right now everybody's really focused right now the man himself how you can arable terrible who's a god-awful pile of garbage
Everyone seems to focus right now. Like legit gonna be a total pilot. Do you usually go into your compositions with some sort of idea?
Yeah, usually like look around and get like some sort of like concept of what I'm gonna do
So not knowing anything of what these
Assets are that is not you know how I like normally work and whatever but I think it's fun to like try things like this
Once in a while because just fun and like it helps you to not always take every piece of art
So seriously that it just can just be like a fun. Good thing. It doesn't have to be this big scary
Thing that you know, you're intimidated to create this is absolute garbage
Being able to do this well because I'm just fucking spending 45 minutes on it. Yeah, that's the thing
I think people's expectations are too high. It's like okay. I don't know what you expected like in 45 minutes
You're gonna come up with this just amazing thing. I mean, maybe these guys will start crying. What's up that kid?
Dylan isn't pretty sweet now. I think just kind of like taking your like
expectations down to kind of a realistic
level
for for something that you're spending a
Small amount of time on each day is the only way that you'll like keep up with it. I can assure you of that
I always had the mindset that this was like each day is one piece
So this picture that I'm making is one right now one force thousand of the project
So that's in some ways how much I care about it because I look at the project is like the everydays
It's a weird mix of like not giving it but also super caring to continue like to do it
Kids look sweet. Okay new direction copying this guy
Japanese caffeine gum son keeps me going in the competition
I didn't she just used my brain. Hopefully my simulation ends before the timers. Okay, this is serious business
Final stretch here. I just the red buff to render out getting my fog right and I'm about to render out
Yeah, not good. Terrible, Tara. What stage did you say you're at right now? They'll fail stage fail
Just under 14
Gary man, I think I'm just gonna let this render out. Let's do it home stretch baby home stretch. I know we won't save
Any winder hopefully it renders out. Okay, I'm stepping away
I'm making no further changes of this but I gotta let it render out and get my axe out ready. I'm shakin 30 minutes 45
I'm just on the hashtags 2 minutes 40 seconds a hashtags. Let's go. You ready to email this to myself?
Quite quick render with the W
That's actually very good
Yeah
Oh
My god, I can't hear that
Started that's what we agreed to you. Just agreed to 12 years
Twelve years an artist
Will see yours last all right
This one was the one I did nice nice work
Are those just cylinders with an emission texture on it? Yeah, I did that same thing. Yeah
That's awesome. You know, I read some things basically the exact same thing is Sam does like hearts around hearts?
That's the best I could do
Is that you getting shot with a laser
The photo scan of me in the mix no and got like a running pose out of it. Yeah
The Irish mist that you were once lost in I know I
Don't know I put a motherboard in you're like
You didn't use the heart this is a mixup on it, you know, like everyone
Like some like techno like thing and then it was just like we have time to actually
Like sort of make it good or make sense what it is dawn
Done doing anything is better than nothing
I mean having that like 45 minute like limit really just made you focus on like. All right, don't worry about anything ambitious
Yeah, it's like can I just get out there? Yeah, yeah
Yeah, I think it's just like really dialing the expectations to like how much time did you actually put on this?
What do you really expect the end piece to be like 45 minutes to me is a sketch dude
Like what you made what you made what you made they're all awesome. Like I'm legitimately impressed
Thank you for giving us this experience and insight into your philosophy. That's super cool. Yeah
Thank you guys, like this place is insane. You got a you got a stockpile there
Just amazing what you guys have like built like super super appreciate the opportunity like I'm still jazz
You guys are a day mm
Sorry to beyond this so follow follow Mike at people underscore crap on Instagram, it's a great handle I
Think it's just people on Twitter, right? Yeah. Yeah on Twitter. It's just people thank you guys
My takeaway is that when you do something every day for 12 years really really counts toward something, you know
I think he really proved a point
Which is he's able to accomplish way way more in 45 minutes than what we can the big thing is take away from Mike's visit
Here is that it doesn't have to be perfect
Just make it just go to make it every ask us like, what do I need to start making movies?
What camera gear do I need is like you have a phone just just go do it the best works of art were created with
A pen and paper. I'll go do it go get your message out there